the year when movies have been super
divisive and generally speaking pretty
disappointing but the animated movies
those have been good that's 2016 in a
nutshell store so storks is an animated
film where storks run a courier service
they used to deliver children you know
the old fable stork drops the baby off
the proportioning outside babies are
made that's what we used to tell kids
like you know back before the internet
now they just know that now they just
always know how ever storks don't
deliver kids anymore now there are
courier service for Amazon pretty much
as I can't say Amazon because of
copyright but it's Amazon there's this
girl who lives there who just turned 18
like Buddy the elf how he grew up with
the elves yeah she grew up with the
storks now the mains darks like by the
way fire her like milton from office
space oh dude who's next in line to
become the boss doesn't fire her then
she accidentally turns on the old dusty
baby-making machine that's actually a
machine
this isn't a metaphor for Anatomy that
thing pops out the baby now that girl
and the stork who's in line to be the
boss stork have to get together and then
go out there and find the babies family
that plot was way way too cumbersome
with Zhang it out loud when you watch
the movie it's not so convoluted as when
I'm talking I just suck at this by the
way but I really enjoyed storks honestly
first of all I dug the humor this movie
has more the movies are comedy generally
speaking the animated films are comedies
this is nothing new here but usually
it's like oh it's a general adventure
with comedy in it I would classify this
as an animated comedy above all and the
characters in here were great they
worked well together I mean they really
it dealt the laughs I was juggling
probably because there's enough humor in
here to appeal to adults really there
are so many parts in this movie where I
was like that's gonna be a gift by the
way when this movie comes out that will
be the new gift like there is a scene
where a couple people have their minds
blown and then it just graphically shows
you their mind being blown and I was
like that's that's the gift and if you
don't see it I'm gonna make it cuz it's
awesome it's just meant to be so much of
that humor worked and bless yes it deals
with babies and parents and people who
might not feel at home you see yeah you
have the heart you have the fields you
have the family dynamic you've got the
tears and yeah I'm now you're alive upon
in this movie I was welling up was like
you it just felt good I mean that's what
I look for in movies like this like
animated movies I'm like okay well kids
be entertained will adults be
entertained does it have the laughs does
it have the feels if it all comes
together boom you have me guys simple
review simple premise storks had the
makings of what I wanted it to have and
what it should have sometimes you feel
like certain parts could have been
edited down to be a little shorter maybe
it's a nitpick in what is otherwise a
very enjoyable cinematic experience for
kids adults families all ages storks is
another animated film in 2016 that
absolutely did it I will say storks is
definitely a good time no alcohol
required in fact I'm gonna bump that one
up to buy it on blu-ray I walked out of
there feeling the magic so there you go
all right guys so storks have you seen
it what did you think about it was your
favorite animated film of 2016 so far
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]